sharks are a vastly diverse group of
species there's 550 of different species
of shark they occupy almost every
aquatic bio region on the planet and you
know in this game called evolution
they've done incredibly well and
diversified to such an extent we see
this amazing diversity of sharks today
sharks are everywhere and have been for
a very long time scientists believe
sharks may have first appeared around
455 million years ago most of these
millions of years they evolved in
relative isolation from humans but new
research suggests however that climate
change and human industry are degrading
shark habitats leading to an uptick in
shark attacks
as humans and sharks converge how can we
prevent mutual harm today we're looking
at emerging technologies designed to
keep humans safe in the water the
challenges in designing these
technologies and whether they need to
exist in the first place
this is damage control
we traveled down to the Bahamas to speak
with some experts on shark human
interactions my name is dr. Owen O'Shea
and I'm the executive director and
principal research scientists for the
Center for ocean research and education
here in the Bahamas well sharks most
sharks anyways sit at the top of the
food chain they're regarded as apex
predators and they they regulate the
food chain from the top they have this
top-down control they're actually
enforcing a harmony within very
complicated coastal and offshore
populations of other sea life that
harmony is increasingly being disrupted
by the influence of humans shark
populations now face man-made dangers
such as longline commercial fishing
thinning habitat destruction and
ecosystem pollution
the Bahamas there's a lot of aggressive
urbanization coastal development cruise
ship terminals dredging that sort of
thing on the other hand humans face a
growing fear of shark attack number of
attacks has risen dramatically over the
past 50 years
climate change is heating waters along
the equator pushing aquatic creatures
poleward according to a study by NOAA
the National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration as sharks seek cooler
water as they come in to increase in
contact with surfers and beachgoers who
flocked to subtropical coastlines in
record numbers more people in the water
means more potential for incident having
evolved in isolation from humans sharks
don't normally see them as food or pose
a threat but changes in habitats have
been shown to provoke changes in
behavior and one bite is often enough to
provoke a significant human response
this woman this unfortunate woman the
victim of the attack a mother of three
she's in the hospital tonight critical
condition the long tough road ahead of
her between 2013 and 2018 there was an
estimated average of 81 unprovoked shark
attacks on humans reported worldwide
some causing fatalities and others not
however varying reports on the number of
those killed by lightning every year
ranged from two thousand six thousand or
even 24,000 people no matter how you
look at it sharks are a substantially
smaller threat to us than lightning
everything is completely sensationalized
and the fact that these interactions are
so rare and relative to the amount of
sharks that are killed by us every year
it's it's just ridiculous because of
this fear the races aren't develop
technologies that will protect water
goers from potential interactions with
sharks but how effective is this
technology
the Bahamas may be the best place in the
world to do a deep dive into these
questions home to one of 21 official
shark sanctuaries the Bahamas have been
instrumental in the rehabilitation of
shark populations DePalma severe Sharkey
even before the shark sanctuary was put
into effect we had tons of sharks I'm
Stuart Cove and I own Stewart goes dive
Bahamas where voice had a very healthy
population sharks it made sense that's
protected now or we have it this is one
of the few places in the world where
sharks are afforded a blanket protection
and therefore one of the most amazing
places to come and see sharks and dive
with sharks in the world it's no wonder
then that the Bahamas is the go-to
destination for researchers around the
world seeking to understand and minimize
shark human interactions wearable
electric field based shark deterrents
such as shark bands and shark shield
theoretically manipulate the sensitive
sensory organs unique to sharks sharp
and is essentially a magnet that you
strapped to your wrist or to your ankle
I'm an evolutionary biologist and so I
study their evolution and have been
studying sharks for about thirty years
when you've got a magnet strapped to
your ankle and you move it up and down
it induces a current now sharks have got
these incredibly sensitive electrical
receptors around this now they're
essentially these tiny pores they can
detect the the my newest of y/o
electrical signals and serve if you've
got it on your ankle and you're kicking
up and down it's gonna generate an
electrical field and if the Sharks
swimming around in this
the shots will recognize that
something's a little bit awry and there
will be deterred and will move away
that's the logic behind it and what we
found is that there wasn't any effect of
the show based on the behavior of the
sharks and the shark Mans didn't reduce
the number of baits being taken by the
shark either and that is because the
effect that the magnets can have on
sharks is limited to a very very close
range and that if you let's say have a
magnet on your ankle on your wrist you
had or your food might be protected
since wearable deterrents drop off at
short range researchers have developed
other technologies to looking at a shark
you wouldn't even think to look for
their ears but a shark's auditory system
is one of the most sophisticated aspects
of the Sharks hunting behavior there
have been some recently published
studies that have suggested that you
know a sudden onset of sound or a very
loud sounds might have some sort of
deterrent effect now in the water it
travels a lot further particularly
low-frequency sound when it's in the
water
you know sharks are known to respond to
a very low sort of frequency up to about
2000 Hertz I think it peaks at about a
hundred Hertz where sharks are sort of
really interested and those that they
are the ranges where you can manipulate
the patterns in that frequency range and
see which patterns induced behaviors
that would suggest that the animals
don't like it and they reversal but can
a universal deterrent even exist each of
these technologies seeks to repel sharks
by manipulating their Anatomy but
therein lies the challenge shots are
incredibly varied a white shark is as
different from a black tip shot as a
human is from a dog so I think some of
these devices can be useful but just
because something works on bull sharks
in the Bahamas does not mean that it's
gonna
danke la popa shots in the Humboldt
Current which is much much colder people
are always trying to find a repellent
that works universally on all shots and
that's a problem and even if we could
find one technology to deter all species
of sharks
should we the problem is that once you
say that something works as a shelter
then people become emboldened and they
think that they're immune and then they
start taking risks that they should not
take another actually seen this myself
when people would be going surfing in
places they wouldn't normally and in
places would it put themself at higher
risk than anything they are because
they're having a device that they think
it works but they actually don't work
researchers say that technology in the
absence of understanding is risky
informing the public and using tools
that better understands the animals I
think it's important to study any animal
really for me personally it's it's an
honor to learn about creatures that I
share this planet with and I think that
we should learn about sharks to
understand really that not only are they
absolutely critical for ecosystem health
and overall health of our oceans but
they really are not the you know sort of
mindless killing machines that the media
certainly tries to make them out to be
we take about 60,000 people to interact
with the sharks and the cool thing about
it is they might come in frightened but
when they leave they're excited about
sharks and now their shark ambassadors
so every year we're creating 60,000
people that go out into the world and
promote the protection of sharks while
attack prevention technology may still
be in development the reality is that
humans pose a far greater threat to
sharks than the other way around
education is the key to understanding
how we can coexist and make for a
stronger and more robust ecosystem
[Music]